>> Tucker: TIME NOW FOR A
"FINAL EXAM" WHERE WE PUT THE
NEWS PROFESSIONALS AGAINST EACH
OTHER TO SEE WHO'S BEEN PAYING
THE CLOSEST ATTENTION.
TONIGHT, IT REALLY THAT MUCH OF
THE CENTURY.
THE TOPICS, THEY MAY BE HARD TO
BELIEVE BUT THERE WERE NEWS
STORIES THIS PAST WEEK THAT HAD
NOTHING TO DO WITH JUDICIAL
CONFIRMATION.
DID ANYONE NOTICE THEM?
WE ARE FINDING OUT.
JOINING US AS GREG GOT FAILED,
AND JUDGE JEANINE PIRRO, HOST OF
JUSTICE WITH JUDGE JEANINE.
WE BOTH KNOW THE RULES AS AVID
WEEKLY VIEWERS OF THIS GAME BUT
I WILL REPEAT THEM FOR OUR
VIEWERS JUST TUNING IN.
CONTESTANTS, AND ON BUZZERS.
I ASKED THE QUESTIONS ON THE
FIRST OF THE TWO OF YOU THAT
BUZZ AND GETS THE QUESTION.
THIS IS A TOUGH ONE, YOU MUST
ALLOW ME TO FINISH ASK YOU
BEFORE YOU SAY THE ANSWER.
IF YOU GET IT WRONG YOU LOSE A
POINT, EACH CORRECT ANSWER IS
WORTH A POINT.
I'M NOW THE JUDGE.
FIRST ONE.
THE MOST FAMOUS PHASE OF THE
PENNSYLVANIA GUBERNATORIAL
DEBATE THIS WEEK WAS THE
MODERATOR.
THE CANDIDATES WERE QUESTIONED
BY WHICH LONGTIME TV GAME SHOW
HOST?
[BUZZ] JUDGE JEANINE PIRRO.
>> ALEX TREBEK.
THE ONE SHE'S RIGHT.
I WILL NOT TOLERATE ANY BOOING
OR HISSING, NOT EVEN IF YOU
DIRECTED AT THE CANDIDATES.
>> Tucker: IT WRONG.
[LAUGHS]
>> WAGONER IS RUNNING FOR
GOVERNOR THERE, I KNOW HIM.
>> Tucker: QUESTION NUMBER
TWO.
WHICH WORLD LEADERS FEATURED IN
A POPULAR NEW CALENDAR THAT
SHOWS HIM RIDING A HORSE,
CUDDLING A LEOPARD AND POSING
SHIRTLESS WITH THE FISH?
GREG GOT FAILED.
>> PUTIN.
>> Tucker: LET'S FIND OUT IF
YOU ARE RIGHT.
>> THERE IS PUTIN WITH A POP.
PUT IN WITH A CUT OF THE,
PUTTING ON A HORSE, AND PUTIN
TAKING THE EPIPHANY DIP IN ICE
WATER.
>> IF A FOREIGNER BUYS THIS
CALENDAR, I WILL DEFINITELY HAVE
A GOOD IMPRESSION OF OUR
PRESIDENT AND THEY WILL SEE THAT
HE CAN DO IT ALL.
HE LOVES ANIMALS, HE CAN SHOOT,
HE LOOKS GOOD AND LOVE SPORTS.
>> Tucker: I DETECT A KIND OF
SARCASTIC TONE IN THAT.
>> IS A VERY MAKE VLAD GREAT
AGAIN.
>> Tucker: I DON'T KNOW, I'M
NOT AGAINST EPIPHANY DIP'S.
QUESTION THREE.
MULTIPLE CHOICE.
RAPPER KANYE WEST IS
WASHINGTON'S NEWEST DIPLOMAT AND
WANTS TO ARRANGE A SITDOWN
MEETING WITH DONALD TRUMP AND
SOME OF THE PRESIDENT HAS LONG
FEUDED WITH.
WHO IS THAT PERSON?
IS IT A -- [BUZZ] >> WAIT, HE
DIDN'T FINISH.
>> Tucker: IT'S
MULTIPLE-CHOICE.
LET ME GIVE YOU THE MULTIPLE
CHOICE.
IT'S THREE CHOICES.
>> THIS ISN'T FAIR.
>> THIS IS WHY WE DON'T WANT
ANCHORS ON THE SHOW.
>> ALL RIGHT, GO AHEAD.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Tucker: THE QUESTION GOES
TO JEANINE PIRRO FIRST ACCORDING
TO OUR JUDGES BECAUSE MR. GOT
FAILED VIOLATED THE CARDINAL
RULES.
>> CALLING CAPRA NICK.
>> Tucker: YOU REALLY THINK
SO?
>> I HAVE BEEN CALLING HIM THIS
THIS'S MORNING, REACHING HIM, SO
I CAN BRING INTO THE WHITE HOUSE
AND SO WE CAN REMOVE THAT
[BLEEP] STATEMENT AND BE ON THE
SAME PAGE.
>> Tucker: YOU SAID BEFORE THE
SHOW THAT YOU THOUGHT YOU WOULD
DO BADLY BECAUSE YOU ONLY FOLLOW
LEGAL NEWS BUT THAT'S NOT TRUE.
>> I FOLLOW NEWS WHEN I'M AWAKE.
>> Tucker: WELL LET'S SEE IF
YOU CAN GET THIS ONE, QUESTION
NUMBER FOUR.
THE PRIME MINISTER OF
GREAT BRITAIN THERESA MAY 8
HEADLINES AROUND THE WORLD WHEN
SHE STARTED AN IMPORTANT SPEECH
WITH AN AWKWARD DANCE.
SHE WAS DANCING LIKE A ROBOT TO
A 1970s DISCO SONG BY A
SWEDISH POP BAND.
WHICH SONG WAS IT?
[BUZZ] YOU ARE JUST JUMPING THE
GUN EVERY TIME.
JUDGES?
TO GREG GOT FAILED.
>> IT'S ABBA.
THE NAME OF THE SONG?
>> IT'S DANCING QUEEN.
>> Tucker: 'S AT DANCING
QUEEN BY ABBA?
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: ALL RIGHT, WE ARE
TWO-2.
THE CONTESTANTS, FINAL QUESTION.
HERE IN NEW YORK CITY,
RESEARCHERS ARE ABOUT TO BEGIN
WORK ON A NEW SENSES.
THIS TIME THEY ARE NOT COUNTING
PEOPLE, HOWEVER.
THEY ARE FOCUSING ON A SMALL
FURRY CREATURE IN CENTRAL PARK.
WHAT KIND OF ANIMAL IS IT?
>> NO, ARE THEY COUNTING?
I WAS WAITING.
YOU HAVE TO READ THE SCRIPT.
>> SHE IS READING THE
TELEPROMPTER.
>> YOU ARE NOT ALLOWED TO READ
THE TELEPROMPTER.
>> I WIN.
>> I DON'T THINK -- THERE IS NO
ANSWER.
>> Tucker: WHEN YOU HAVE CABLE
NEWS ANCHORS ON YOUR SHOW,
THINGS CAN FALL APART.
LET ME CHECK WITH THE JUDGES
REALLY QUICK.
>> THE JUDGES SAY THE HOST OF
THE PROGRAM IS ALLOWED TO ADD
LIVE ON HIS OWN SCRIPTS.
I THINK THAT'S -- SHE'S READING
IT.
SO GREG GOT FAILED, WHAT IS THE
ANSWER?
>> I'M GOING TO SAY SQUIRRELS.
>> WHY WOULD IT NOT BE RATS?
IS IT SQUIRRELS?
>> NEW YORK CITY IS ABOUT TO
CONDUCT ITS FIRST OFFICIAL
SQUIRREL CENSUS NEXT WEEK,
VOLUNTEERS ARE NEEDED.
>> Tucker: THIS IS LITERALLY
THE MOST CONTENTIOUS SHOW WE'VE
EVER HAD TO.
>> BUT I WON.
>> IT'S NOT FAIR.
>> Tucker: WE WILL GIVE ONE TO
YOU LATER.
>> I WANT ONE.
>> Tucker: FOR OUR VIEWERS, WE
DESCRIBED HIM NIGHT AFTER NIGHT
AS A "WASHINGTON POST" WRITER
AND IT TURNS OUT HE'S NOT.
HE WORKS FOR A WEBSITE.
BUT IF YOU DON'T KNOW WHO HE IS,
THIS IS ERIC ONE POLL, THE GUY
ON THE MUG.
WATCH.
>> BE NINE MITZVAH JEWISH
WEDDING, WHAT A GREAT
OBLIGATION.
HOW DO THEY DO ALL THIS GREAT
CONTENT FOR FREE?
IT'S GOT ALL THESE GREAT TIPS ON
THINGS.
THE AUTHOR OF THE STORY IS A
CATERER.
WE CHECKED.
THEY DO HAPPY HOUR SPECIALS.
>> Tucker: YOU CAN'T GET
ENOUGH OF THAT, WE GOT MORE ON
HER FACEBOOK PAGE AND I WOULD
STRONGLY RECOMMEND IT.
>> WHERE DID YOU FIND THAT?
>> Tucker: WE HAVE A CRACK
RESEARCH TEAM.
THERE HE IS, ERIC WEMPLE FROM
"THE WASHINGTON POST" WEBSITE.
>> I WANT A COFFEE MUG.
>> I DON'T WANT IT.